alexandre longo à bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
dénoncé l'impunité policière face au
racisme et aux violences et message est
lancé hier par ces milliers de
manifestants alors bien sûr on ne peut
pas tout mettre tout le monde dans le
même sac ou généralisée mais est ce que
vous comprenez cette colère envers les
forces de l'ordre lors on comprend cette
colère le problème c'est que pour doit
elle est mal dirigé que la colère
devrait plutôt être contre notre
employeur l'état qui laisse faire en
fait que nous dénonçons ces violences
policières nous dénonçons ce racisme au
sein d'institutions qui le rappelle a
tué nos collègues en 2010 un crs qui se
faisait traiter de badamia par son
commandant de compagnie et qui s'est
suicidé à cause de ça et il ya eu aucune
sanction au niveau du commandante
nous rappelons également carassins des
quatre pistes et police tunis syndicat
sgp qui avait dit pour bull assez
convenable il n'a eu aucune sanction
quand notre délégué noah manoir s'est
élevé contre les propos racistes qu'il
avait donc l'appui de témoin et encore
dernièrement sur ce qui est arrivé à
notre collègue à rouen il avait prédit
qu'il m'aurait une collecte sera
toujours en quoi c'était n'aurait rien
qui est le cas aujourd'hui
donc en fait cette minorité nuisible de
gens violents dans la police et qu'en
dehors des cadres légaux et des gens
racistes en fait aux problèmes également
aux policiers et la colère nous la
comprenons mais elle doit être dirigée
contre notre employeur alors il ya donc
un racisme des policiers parfois sur le
terrain mais également au sein même de
votre vos rangs est ce que quand on est
confronté justement au terrain est ce
que on est bien préparés finalement il
ya aussi également effectivement un
problème de formation le programme ne
sommes pas préparés car nous avons deux
formations qui est pas terrible en plus
le niveau du concours abc même avec un
niveau de concours élan baissier sous
l'air de monsieur macron les gens a été
recruté à 8 de moyenne
et finalement les gens sont envoyés sur
le terrain dans des régions qu'ils ne
connaissent pas dire qu'en fait non plus
jeunes collègues tombés hier les quatre
il est plus difficile et c'est un peu
partout malheureusement dans la fonction
publique la même chose alors qui mise à
jour 2 ans d'expérience qui ont
l'expérience de la vie du cames et
cetera
mais je vais reprendre les propos d'un
mes collègues qui avait dit moi j'ai été
affecté dans un quartier populaire de la
première année de ma carrière
le bout d'un an j'ai demandé à partir
parce qu'il était en train de devenir
ainsi je ne me reconnaissais plus donc
en fait l'institution policière en plus
de ne pas
tricher elles forment malheureusement en
laissant des gens dans des situations
compliquées avec des noms préparation
sur le terrain il ya le parquet de paris
a ouvert une enquête après les
révélations de l'enquète streetpress sur
des messages racistes publié sur
facebook des messages très virulent est
ce que c'est un acte isolé à votre avis
où est ce qu'il y à d'autres groupes de
ce genre qui circulent alors par il faut
toujours relativiser ce que ce groupe
est à l'image des autres groupes de la
politique ou également de la police
nationale en général et que les prêtres
que l'a bien souligné mais personne ne
l'a remarqué c'est que c'est des
messages de quelques dizaines de
collègues sur un groupe de huit mille
personnes
donc en fait c'est une fois de plus des
gens qui agissent en meute qui disent
dès que quelqu'un c'est de les
contredire sur leurs propos racistes
homophobes et tout ce qu'on veut il
débarque en dix ans et policiers ont
fait ce qu'on veut mais finalement sur
la totalité des personnes de ce groupe
c'est une minorité qui pose problème
après sur facebook il n'est pas très
difficile de modérer ce qui se passe
donc il ya d'autres groupes où il aura
des petits muller qui pourront être
tenus mais par contre il faut pas jeter
la pierre à tout le monde parce que
finalement là aussi ça démontre bien que
c'est une minorité dangereuse contre
lequel l'état ne lutte pas il ne lui pas
c'est pour ça qu'ils se permettent de
tenir ces propos sur des réseaux sociaux
on l'a dit un certain de vos collègues
dénoncent le racisme qui se trouve même
au sein de la police on a vu des images
aux états unis où les policiers
participer à cette mobilisation massive
ces derniers jours est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer
voilà dans le futur que la police elle
aussi battent le pavé aux côtés des
manifestants pour dénoncer ce racisme
bas nous on aimerait bien que ça se
passe parce que celles effectivement la
police nationale est à l'image de la
population et puis des gens chez nous
sont victimes de racisme également les
gens effectivement rentrer chez nous
pour lutter contre le racisme parce que
le racisme n'est pas une opinion c'est
un délit
donc la police nationale doit faire
respecter la loi et donc nous aimerions
bien le faire mais malheureusement
certains syndicalistes ont peur de la
convergence des lustres de six unités
gp2 l'a dit sur votre antenne
il y a quelques jours au niveau des
violences policières donc c'est un
problème nous nous sommes à intégrer la
société dont % caprices de vivre dans la
société
et si nous étions dans ces
manifestations la ce serait quelque
chose de bien encore faut-il que les
personnes votre manifestation là ne crie
pas des slogans qui amalgame tous les
policiers en vie dans tout le monde
déteste de la police
c'est une aberration qui n'engendre que
la haine les amalgames dans portant rien
de bon de chaque côté merci beaucoup
alexandre langlois d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie
police